hi everybody so in this recording i will
look into
how formal methods and
reinforcement learning could work
together and
help develop verifiable reinforcement
learning algorithms and
this is one way of abstractly studying
how the recent developments in learning
and reinforcement learning could provide
alternative means for a number of
functionalities in
in cyber physical systems but on the
other hand
these new techniques uh don't yet put
the necessary emphasis on the safety or
correctness
of the under of the resulting behavior
and and it is questionable whether
they can work with
realistic amounts of data given the fact
that
cyber physical systems and autonomous
systems are actually
they have physical environment and there
might be limitations on
on how much data we can
generate for training and learning
purposes
especially given that they are to work
in dynamic environments
and and not necessarily everything in
the environment is going to cooperate
with us for uh observing these systems
uh for training and learning purposes
so on one side learning offers
opportunities on the other side
whether we can verify the safety of the
resulting behavior
and whether the data requirements are
realistic that's this is
it is the tension between these two ends
and what i'm going to do is as i said
i will use reinforcement learning this
interaction between formal methods and
learning could
uh play in many different forms i'm
going to look into that in the
in the context of reinforcement learning
and reinforcement learning is
essentially there is a learner's race
robot a system uh that
works in an environment and there are
certain things that
does not know yet it needs to uh
it needs to operate in the environment
so typically it is a
back and forth between what happens in
the environment and the learner
learning takes an action something
happens in the environment learner gets
to see what's happened
and and it may also gets a thumbs up or
thumbs down
from some entity that guides the
learning process
for the learners and obviously this is
the
highest level cartoonish explanation of
reinforcement learning
and there could be many different
variants of this
and it it it it has it offers
a lot of capabilities and the
success stories are in
are expanding uh pretty quickly uh
on the other hand uh still there
it is possible that a learning enabled
uh functionality actually
can behave in ways that are obviously
not acceptable
uh given the safety criticality of many
of uh cyber physical systems and
autonomous systems
we have to think twice uh whether we
understand the resulting functionality
properly or not
and to this end let us introduce
a new piece of problem data let us
modify the problem
tiny bit we will introduce a temporal
logic specification
and ask the question of whether the
learned behavior satisfies the
specification it could be a safety
specification it could be something else
that we care about
we will ask whether the system the
resulting
learned behavior is going to satisfy the
specifications or a little harder but
not
a little bit significantly harder and
more interesting question is that
actually
whether even during learning in the in
the face
the system does not know certain things
which
might actually become uh critical for
for safety properties
uh whether we can actually keep the
system safe while
ensuring that it figures out those
things that it does not
yet know so that is this is the this is
the
rough problem description i'm going to
look into uh in the in the rest of these
slides
there is a very closely related method
so called inverse reinforcement learning
and the later parts i'm going to touch
on that where
an expert essentially shows what
acceptable behavior is
and then the learner out of these
demonstrations
tries to figure out how to operate and
specifications in this context will come
in
in a slightly different way but
they will offer similar they will offer
similar from
utility so with that let me now just
move into
one sample problem uh
is not necessarily the most
most recent or most realistic setting
but it is going to be a way to for us to
put
concepts from formal methods and
concepts from reinforcement learning
together
so we have given is a markov decision
process
and we know the structure we know what
transitions exists and we
but we may not know the transition
function we may not know the transition
probabilities
so the transition probability matrix is
unknown again we know the structure
uh that assumption could be removed but
let's save it in a video
and we we are given a temporal logic
specification as well
and we are asked to synthesize a
strategy f
um and
it's going to obviously choose the
actions for the for the learning agent
such that
we will maximize the probability of
satisfying specifications
there is no additional reward in this in
this in this first setting
we want to maximize this fact we want to
learn something that maximizes the
satisfaction the probability of
satisfying specifications
and since we don't know the transition
probabilities there's going to be some
sort of
trial and error or learning is going to
take place and we want this thing to be
efficient in some classical sense which
is the pack sense probably approximately
correct sense
it's going to mean so
we will we will not have so we probably
won't be able to get the optimal policy
so we want to be near optimal
and we will probably not be totally
confident in what we will get so we want
some high confidence and roughly
probably an approximate to
refer to those two things and then we
don't want to that
this thing they take forever we want to
be able to have a bound on that
we can do this near optimality and high
confidence with some
amount of time and samples that are
polynomial
in the key parameters of the problem
so we want to have a polynomial bound
on the learning effort so this is the
problem
that we will look into and uh and the
first insight from formal methods
comes right away that uh instead of
trying to look into the system and the
specifications we will obviously
um transform this thing to a product
automaton
a specific an automaton that represents
the specifications we'll take the
product
we know the structure we don't know the
transition probabilities but that's fine
and the resulting system is going to be
yet another
markov decision process but now uh
certain parts of that market
decision process will be unknown and in
instead of
monitoring uh the specifications we will
just look into whether certain special
states obviously
uh in this product at all time or in
this product mdp will be visited or
uh with what probability they will be
visited
so we will transform it to a product
system and
we will then use uh roughly existing
learning techniques
on this product system and uh
so the solution which is adopted from
uh the so-called e3 algorithm in
reinforcement learning
uh looks just
follows this this flow so we we won't
know the m the markov decision process
but at each step we will have an
estimate on it and let's call it m bar
and we have the specification then given
m bar
and specification we can go and compute
a strategy
f using standard techniques that we have
seen earlier in the week
and then then we will apply this
strategy on the on the actual system and
we will see what happens
and during this process we will see we
will gather
new data and we will go and update our
understanding of the underlying market
decision process we will
update the estimated them and this
roughly looks into
i haven't i have been to the state i
have taken this action
let me count what happens i end up here
here and here 17 times 200 times etc
that gives an estimate of the underlying
transition unknown transition
probabilities
and then and then we close the loop and
repeat it
for us for certain amount of times so
that's the how the flow works
and along this process what happens
uh what happens is the following so
first of all
we will have known certain parts of the
markov decision process
those are the parts for which we already
have a relatively good estimate of the
underlying
unknown transition probabilities roughly
we can't think this as that the parts of
the
state space at which we have been
sufficient many times and
try to cut things sufficiently many
times and then the rest that we will
lump into a single sync state
and then the first result is in the form
of
that the policy that we compute over the
known part
of the product system is either near
optimal hence we can't stop we know that
with this much of knowledge we can say
that this policy is going to give
high enough uh probability for
satisfying the underlying specifications
or it is going to explore it's not going
to get stuck
it is going to run into a new unknown
state but non-zero probability
so we have either have seen enough that
we are near optimal or we will see new
things
all right so this is the first step that
says that
it is not going to be in a case where
either the probability
is uh too far from the
maximal probability or
uh we cannot see anything new so that
that's up that obviously is a
non-fruitful uh term uh
uh status that we we want to avoid and
this theorem says that that's not going
to happen you will either
inch toward the maximum probability or
you are you are done
and then the final the end result here
is that
uh indeed we can by going through this
loop
we can go and uh with
probability 1 minus delta delta is given
some
small constants and epsilon is like that
too
so with probability 1 minus delta
the resulting policy is going to satisfy
this inequality here
so this one is the effect we had known
what the
if we had known what the markov decision
process was this was this is the maximal
problem that we could have obtained and
this is
uh the problem that we achieve by
the policy that we compute in each
iteration
so eventually we will have this case
that the
gap between these two probabilities will
be less than two epsilon
and is not going to so this is the
approximately optimal part
this is the uh high confidence part
and uh the number of samples that we
need or the number of steps that we will
need is polynomial in the size of the
markov decision process size of this
automaton that represents the
specification
it is t is the so-called epsilon state
value mixing time for the optimal policy
that is there's a lot there's a little
bit commonly used
cheating there but uh so uh
the the up the end result depends on
that constant
as well polynomially and the uh
it also depends on the amount of
confidence and amount of
sub-optimality that we can tolerate
polynomially
so this is pretty straight forward that
observing that
we can monitor with respect to the
specifications by passing to a product
automaton with unknown elements in it
and then
going applied a a variant of an existing
reinforcement learning algorithm
and then establish similar balanced on
on this over this product automotive
and translate that back to that the
specifications
in the end result uh will be satisfied
with a probability that's not too far
from the optimal
okay so let's look at a little example
um
so let me try to explain we have a
motion planning problem or a grid world
the objective is maximizing the
probability of satisfying this
specification here written
in text infinitely often visiting the
green blocks
green blocks that we see r1 r2 r3
in this order
uh and then never get into the
red cells and there are four different
types of
uh terrain
and we we don't know uh
what is where or what the transition
probabilities are
and this blue thing is the position of
the system or the
robot or the agent that is starting from
certain place and goes and explores and
sees what happens and tries to find out
the transition probabilities in these
different regions
and based on that at some point it's
going to stop
and uh and then we can
do this is not very informative
animation
what we can see is that actually there
is a little bit of a trade-off between
how much sub-optimality we can
tolerate versus how much computation we
need if we are fine to be
off by 0.01 then we have to run for a
long time
and if you can tolerate being off by
0.05
the computation time reduces
significantly
and a little comment here that the
the time that we spent for synthesizing
the policy over the estimated markov
decision process in that loop
is actually the negligible part of it
the most of the time that
i'm reporting here is essentially the
system is going
and just bumping into things and taking
actions and seeing what's happening
essentially the learning effort takes
forever whereas the
uh the the synthesis over the estimated
markov decision process is
uh almost negligible time with respect
to that
exploration effort so uh
fine so just let me just now create this
results
to as a transition to some other set of
results
so this is indeed actually a relatively
rigorous framework that brings in
the formal methods like ideas and
reinforcement learning like ideas into
a uh into a setting it is data efficient
in a theoretical sense we know that
there's a polynomial bound on the effort
that we need for learning
yet even in this relatively
small example learning may take forever
and and not only that but
these specifications are satisfied with
high probability only at
convergence and if you look at the uh
the animation in the previous slide we
would have see closely we would have
seen that
uh actually sometimes this system goes
and
visits the red cells that wants to avoid
during training
and not too surprising because the
underlying
the underlying
transition probabilities are unknown and
we only ask that at convergence the
specification is satisfied with high
probability
so this is this is really the good part
and there are there are not so good
parts
the theoretical efficiency may not be
there to be absolutely practically
useful because we will be working with
relative like
physical systems most of time uh cyber
physical systems and
and and autonomous systems trying things
million times or billion times
in a physical in the physical world is
not going to be
effective and also
as i said high probability at
convergences may not be acceptable if my
system dies before it learns
that learning is not going to be that
useful
so we want to keep the system safe and
explore to the extent that it's possible
so i'm going to now go through a couple
of different ideas that had been
explored
for essentially motivated by these two
limitations
what is that so uh this is this is an
extension of the previous results where
now the system description is a
turn-based stochastic book again
and the transition probabilities are
unknown
we have a reward now the reward is
unknown as well
so it is not only while we are uh
running in the system not only by
maximizing the satisfaction probability
of the specifications but
along with that let's also satisfy the
let's also maximize the reward that the
system collects but the reward is
unknown
at various states
and actually the problem statement or
the
the statement of the end result is going
to be
slightly different than that and i'm
going to come to that in a second
we also have a discount factor the
rewards that i collect now are more
important than those in the future
and similarly we have this epsilon and
delta for
sub optimality and confidence so now
it is actually not maximizing the uh it
is not trying to maximize the
satisfaction probability instead
what we will end up having is an almost
sure winning almost surely the
specification will hold
uh with probable sorry
with probability one the specification
will hold
and the system is going to behave
epsilon sub optimally
perhaps initially uh
but it is not going to be uh
for too long there's going to be the end
result is that there is a
memoryless strategy with
probability no less time one minus delta
with high confidence
it's going to be almost surely safe or
almost surely satisfying specification
and it will all behave possibly
sub-optimally
up to a level of more than
epsilon sub-optimally only initially
and that initial fragment is not is
going to be bounded
uh by a polynomial that is a that's
that's a function of this size of the
state space size of the automaton that
we have
for uh underlying automotive sorry
uh this is um the size of the
the game already captures this uh so the
size of the state space
size of the action set and uh related to
the level of confidence and level of
sub-optimality that we want to tolerate
so to some extent this takes away this
tension that we may actually not satisfy
the specifications
and die before we learn uh
with further assumptions
in uh and changing the problem a little
bit
this says that this result is not
subject to that criticism
it is going to be safe or it's going to
satisfy specifications
almost surely with high probability at
all times and that part is obviously is
going to relate to
the fact that we know the underlying
structure
we don't know the transition
probabilities we don't know the rewards
but we know the structure in this game
and that part is going to be leveraged
for this first piece
and the unknown rewards and unknown
transition probabilities
will be morphed into that we may behave
suboptimally but not for too long
okay so this is this is one uh one
um one fix for uh
for the criticism that i had in the
previous slide and
also i should have a couple of comments
on that
uh the problem that we are i am trying
to motivate
uh by this slide that we want
we want to be able to do things in
unknown systems we want to be able to
save we want to be able to efficient
likely that that that the objective that
i'm setting is not achievable
in the in in a general setting hence the
the effort has been focusing on hey
let's look at into
various versions of this of of this
of this uh objective and this one is
uh making progress toward that in a
in a in one setting that is obviously
narrower than the general objective
another approach that has been uh looked
into and
is attracting more and more interest is
this uh safety through shielding
and this is definitely motivated by the
uh
by the shielding work over the last
five to ten years in formal methods and
asking
how it can be utilized for reinforcement
learning purposes
so this is the flow of reinforcement
learning that i showed early on
now what's going to happen is we will
cut the flow
and say look if the learner might take
an action but we'll introduce a runtime
shield that's going to get that's going
to see
the action it also may have access to
the
observations and it is going to get to
modify the actions
and then the modified action is going to
be implemented in the environment
and then then the rest is closed in a
similar way
and this runtime shielding approach is
desired and
in some techniques it is actually
probably achieved that
it's going to be corrected with respect
to underlying specifications
and not necessarily a very general
family of specifications but for the
safety fragment of
linear temporal logic definitely there's
quite a bit of
work so we want them to be correct in
the sense that
the learner might take actions that were
to violate the specifications but the
modified actions when they are
implemented
we don't want this this resulting
behavior in the environment to violate
the safety
specifications uh so
correctiveness could have been achieved
uh by just
overwriting every single action of the
learner and that's definitely not what
we want and we want this these
corrective actions to be minimally
interfering interfere only when
a violation was going to be unavoidable
and
and as soon as you fix these things uh
return the authority back to the learner
so that the learner can
do whatever what it was supposed to do
to take advantage of
exploring the world and extracting
extracting performance out of that
perhaps
and uh to a
great extent these techniques are
they do not refer to the inner workings
of the learning algorithm
they just look into the the input output
relations
hence they actually are agnostic to the
underlying learning algorithms
and there are ways to extend them to
function approximation based methods for
learning
even that is a
essentially that is trying to allude to
that we can use these techniques which
with learning algorithms that represent
the underlying unknown
elements using for example neural
networks
and if the underlying learning algorithm
has some theoretical properties for
example some convergence properties
we don't often have these things but
some more conventional learning
algorithms reinforcement learning
algorithms have
convergence guarantees we want the
shielded version to obviously preserve
some of these
those guarantees it is not this is the
shielding is the shielded learning is
not necessarily going to
converge to what the original learning
algorithm was going to converge to
because it may be
not possible even but we want these
things to converge to the constrained
optimal behavior
again this doesn't happen too often
because the baseline learning techniques
do not necessarily have this property
but if they do and in some cases
the shielded learning has been able to
preserve the properties
and also it turns out that by
an interesting manner restricting the
exploration space
shielded learning has been uh has
demonstrated some empirical
increase in the data efficiency for
learning
so how shield synthesis works is roughly
described by this
flow let me open these things so
essentially
it relies only violation monitor that is
going to
monitor whether the underlying system
the learner is to
violate the specifications and if it is
if it is the case then the violation
monitor
goes and keeps track of the all possible
executions that could have avoided the
violation of the specifications
and then it the deviation one third
keeps track of uh once the shield
actually
starts deviating from the learner's
directives it looks into how much the
deviation is and
it keeps track of that this element here
solves a safety game and
essentially it computes a permissive
strategy
over a safety game that ensures that the
when
the resulting strategy permissive
strategy from this game
uh when it is implemented on top of the
learners the resulting behavior is going
to satisfy the safety specifications
so this ensures the correctness
and the last element ensures by solving
another game
uh that is obtained by
essentially putting this permissive
strategy on top of the underlying
the initial game that we had uh it
ensures that
uh the shield is not going to forever
mess up
with the operation of the learner but at
some point
as soon as possible it is going to uh
once it
corrects the behavior it is going to
give the authority back to the
to the learners and then overall
uh we by composing properly the these
elements that we have
we obtain this shield a couple of
examples here
so this is a simple example actually
this car is trying to figure out how to
drive around the circuit
and is going to use a reinforcement
learning algorithm
uh with the i believe the policy is
represented as a
three layer neural network uh and on the
left
this this animation shows um
learning process without shielding and
this one shows with shielding
and let me go back and come back come to
this
essentially it is a random exploration
here and there
and then for without shielding
after 40 minutes of training and 1600
crashes
uh it doesn't seem like that the
learner actually have figured out it's
supposed to be which
is going around the circuit uh whereas
uh within one minute of training and no
crashes because the shield actually
ensures that they do not exist as you
can see
the shielded version have figured out a
way to go around the circuit
and what happens is essentially the
shield without allowing for
crashes uh it gives a little bit of a
better chance to
uh proceed uh in the in the direction
uh in which the uh learner can gather
rewards for doing things properly in
this case
uh going around this at least once as
soon as you go around this at least once
uh you start seeing um rewards
that's going to reinforce your
understanding of what you are probably
supposed to do
whereas this one never actually
in this in this one training episode
it never finishes this it goes
around the circuit and it never achieves
to see a single reward
so what we have observed is that
indeed merging ideas from formal methods
and
reinforcement learning has a tremendous
utility when
for these systems where the reward is
delayed or the
tasks for for completing which the
system gets a reward
has this extended horizon or
temporally extended tasks are harder to
learn
because the rewards are relatively
sparse and
guidance from ideas
guidance from formal methods based ideas
are relatively useful for such learning
tasks
and um and here i show a
pac-man example over a small grid world
others have probably much larger
examples and with increasing number of
ghosts in in a pac-man example but what
we see here is that
the shielded version never gets eaten
hence it actually
not only gets more score but it figures
out how to do things
much more effectively than uh the united
shielded version where
uh the pacman gets eaten pretty often
uh okay so this is one way of looking
into it and
another question now i'm going to ask
and i'm
switching now uh to the second part
where whether we can actually make
learning more efficient by incorporating
by through connections between
formal methods and and reinforcement
learning
and the setting is the following can we
have two tasks
a source task and a target task task is
going to now have
uh this time temporal logic
like setting and um and
the that language had been uh picked for
this line of work mostly for so that the
inference that comes inferring
uh temporal logic specifications from
demonstrations
uh to to facilitate that step
but essentially what happens is we have
we have these yellow region yellow
region green region green region
they are at different places they look
different
there is some time aspect of these
specifications
but what we see here is that
[Music]
these the tasks on the two sides
seem similar to each other structurally
they are similar
the exact timing is different there's a
region the reasons place is different
the size is different blah blah but
there's some similarity between
these two tasks so the question is
whether we can actually take advantage
of this similarity
by the source task is
there is there is you'll learn in the
source task
and then the question is now if we were
to learn in a new
in a new environment for our new tasks
whether we can
take advantage of the similarity
and the fact that we have already taken
the pain of learning
in this source task it is essentially
whether we can have transfer of
capability
from from left to right in this picture
and what's going to happen is again as i
said we will learn
on this site while doing it as we gather
data we will infer
specifications and the similarity
between these specifications
the logical similarity that this slide
calls it is going to give us confidence
that
we should be able to take advantage of
what we have learned in the
sorry in this indeed
in the source task and then
make the learning in the target task
more efficient in the in the sense of
using the use of data and um
so i'm not going to get into the what
happens in each step of these things
but let me look at an example so the
source task
and the target task
are shown here and i show i show you
four learning examples
in the target task the first one
uses the so-called q-learning algorithm
with no more guidance
and the optimal behavior here is
gathering this cumulative reward of 100
and the q-learning algorithm does a
couple of things here and then starts to
increase uh but the increase is way too
slow and if you run this for millions of
steps
it is just going to inch toward the
higher but it will never get to the
optimal behavior
whereas now if we we will have inferred
these
specifications right we now
uh extend the state space by
incorporating the specification
and then also there are multiple
different ways of
inferring the different metrics
for how well the inference of these
specifications from the data
is and if we use as a metric the maximum
classification rate
uh in the in the in the mixed uh
not mixed metric into interval temporal
logic
in its specifications what we see is
that this per
this pin curve a couple of things here
one is that in the initial
i believe 10 000 steps here the pink
color actually stays
zero because those initial episodes
initial runs
the this method uses for establishing
whether there is a logical similarity
between what we had seen
in the source task and this in this new
target task
why it is established and there are
there are ways to do it
proposed for concluding that
there's sufficient similarity then it
starts
collecting reward and what we see is
that it
uses the first 10 000 steps for
establishing logical similarity and then
once there is a logical similarity
it actually interests toward the optimal
level much faster than what we see in
the black curve
and if for inference a different
metric is used we but what is called
this informativeness of the resulting
um mixed integer sorry metric interval
temporal logic specifications
we obtain this blue thing so again
initially there's nothing
but then it just goes toward the optimal
behavior in this case it actually gets
pretty close to the optimal behavior
and then this this last piece is it is
also
taking the low level learned objects the
reward representations etc and using it
as a
warm start for learning in the target
and task
the long story short is that with a
little
more effort on trying to establish this
logical similarity
by using ideas from formal methods
in this setting one can make actually
learning
in a new environment significantly uh
more effective
and efficient data efficient than it
would have been
if it tried to learn from scratch more
optimal
much more data efficient and and and
and it is using the underlying
similarity between the tasks that are
captured
in in variants of temporal logic
specifications so the last piece i'm
going to get into
is essentially this inverse
reinforcement learning
and let me not spend too much time on it
and just
tell you what the main idea is the main
idea is somebody shows you what to do
somehow
a human walks somebody controls a car
a teacher shows a robot what to do bunch
of demonstrations
in this case these are the
demonstrations that we have
and and from these demonstrations
you call you run inverse reinforcement
learning which is essentially from the
demonstrations and then given a
remarkable decision process you try to
come up with a reward function
initially unknown and you try to
construct that in such a way that
the policy that uh optimizes with
respect to this reward function
is going to mimic the expert
demonstrations
that is the that is the that is the
metric for this inverse problem
and what we
i'm going to call inverse reinforcement
learning but with high level task
information site information is going to
put temporal logic specifications into
this mix it is not only the
demonstrations
but it's also that we know every
possible demonstration
would have satisfied some given
specifications
it says here that every possible
demonstrations would never come to these
red cells here
right and it would go to these green
cells in certain ways and eventually go
to this
yellow cell and another way of thinking
about this let's say this is
somebody's driving behavior and this is
the driver's handbook
there's no reason whatsoever trying to
figure out what
driver's handbook every same driver
would have followed
from the demonstrations of driving right
so how can we feed these things
and learn something that not only mimics
the demonstrations
not only tries to create behavior that
would look similar
around where we have these
demonstrations but also satisfies the
uh these these tasks the site
information or the specifications that
we use to capture this the the
underlying
knowledge with high probability
and and this slide shows
essentially a way of solving the
resulting problem
the resulting problem is uh has
typically
roughly two pieces this initial part
describes
how to parameterize the underlying
unknown reward functions and how to
obtain
an optimal policy out of it a randomized
policy
and and the
here the objective is maximizing the
picking the parameters theta that
represent the reward function in such a
way that
the resulting behavior is going to
generate
the resulting policy is going to which
is this the resulting pulse is going to
generate
behavior in the markov decision process
and that looks similar to the
demonstrations d
and uh we encode the optimality through
the the belmont equations
as constraints here and the um
the underlying um
the modification is going to be now i
don't know how to erase these things let
me just
okay the modification is in the
following way
in addition to now the dominant equation
the optimality conditions
are over the product space again the
markov decision process and then the
automaton
corresponding to the underlying the
specifications that capture the
knowledge that we have
and in addition to that we keep track of
whether the specifications are violated
and we penalize in the objective
function
all right so just we penalize violating
these the specifications
in addition to being uh similar to
in uh being similar to the underlying
demonstration so there's going to be a
trade-off between
being similar and while satisfying the
specifications
it turns out that there are a couple of
neat properties that we can get
this left side does not use any side
information right side uses
and and yellow is probability one or
high probability of
satisfying specifications starting from
the
states show what we see that actually
obviously these
starting from the obstacles we cannot
satisfy the specifications we will
already violate the specifications and
hence very low probability these are not
surprising here
but from then many other places
especially this top right corner
we also violate the specifications if we
don't use the site information if we
just use the
plain outcome of the inverse
reinforcement learning
not surprising because if we go back you
see that
we don't have data from those regions
nothing has been seen the universal
reinforcement learning has no idea
what's going on
and and and
and then therefore actually it is going
to violate specifications with high
profile
when we incorporate site information as
we do as
i showed then we have yellow from
everywhere but the
um but the obstacles
and that means that actually from any
state
uh depend no matter whether we have seen
data in those states or not
we will satisfy the specifications with
high probability so
this is good for satisfying
specifications the next question is is
this actually at the expense of not
creating behavior
that looks like demonstrations and it
turns out that
it is not this is uh with the
relative weights between the similarity
to demonstrations and satisfying
specifications
we can create very low probability of
satisfying specifications
versus very high probability of
justifying the specifications
so this is the relative weight and there
is a
level of weight where we can get high
satisfaction probability
and also around that
where we have we have high satisfaction
probability
the similarity to the underlying
demonstrations is not
almost at all different from the
similarity to
the demonstrations for any other
relative
weight that we have hence
in this one example at the least the
significantly better test satisfaction
probability
does not necessarily come with a
sacrifice
of not making the user happy or not
being similar to what the user or what
the expert has shown
as demonstrations in university
enforcement learning
so with that i'm going to actually wrap
up here
i wanted to just comment on why we
should care about the
ideas in the interface of foreign
learning and
my reasoning it is evolving but it goes
as follows
learning we cannot be we cannot say that
we will not use learning in one way or
other it is going to come into
cyber physical systems or autonomous
systems
but uh learning based techniques are no
way reliable to be used for
autonomy or in general even in
engineering and
what i think is this the main bottleneck
is not necessarily underlying ideas are
bad
this is just the specifications are
nowhere we just we cannot talk about
verifiable we cannot talk about safety
we cannot talk about reliability
assurance whatever is just the right
buzzword out there is
we cannot talk about that stuff without
first giving clear specifications of
what it's going to mean
and to me this is the biggest uh benefit
that
we can get from the interaction between
formal methods and learning
and formal specifications will not only
tell us what
we are trying to achieve
but they happen to be actually also
pretty nice
uh representations compact
representations
of existing knowledge and
and there's quite a bit of debate out
there in learning
just how to incorporate existing
knowledge
and data and to come up with hybrid
techniques
and again there are different types of
buzzwords
for such representations and techniques
and
very likely uh that if we can take
advantage of existing knowledge and
incorporate that into learning we can
probably improve the efficiency of these
techniques
and start talking about reliable to your
trustworthiness of these techniques much
more
confidently and specifications formal
specifications
uh giving us a way to translate our
knowledge into
algorithm development relatively
systematically
is i think also a very nice opportunity
and sometimes merely acknowledging that
hey
we need behavior specifications we
cannot tolerate daydreaming we cannot
tolerate
just going and trying out something
empirically i had a hunch let me just go
and tweak my neural network in this way
add one more layer etc that that's great
if you can get performance out of it but
merely acknowledging that i need to
specify the behavior the desired
behavior that then i can take with this
behavior specification and incorporate
my resulting learning algorithm into an
engineering system
without the proper specifications we
cannot go and incorporate learning
into a bigger engineering product merely
that
type of self-discipline might be
actually a breakthrough
and on the flip side um learning based
techniques modern learning based
techniques seem to give
efficient ways of manipulating data and
keeping track of what we had
seen and that might
prove useful for constructing
approximate solutions
or alternative approximate solutions for
problems that we face very hard problem
to face in formal methods
that are known to be hard i am
more willing to take a best effort
empirically a best effort approximation
that seems to be empirically working
mo i am more easily to accept such a
solution
if i know that an exact
complete and formal solution is uh
probably extremely hard uh so
that is the flip side of the coin and i
know people are actually also
exploring the connections between forum
let's down learning uh for those
purposes as well
so with this i'm going to wrap up here
and and then we can discuss these things
further thanks